we do not have
powerful
organized institutionalized opposition
in this country to the liberal
establishment to the ruling class you
want to see a great example of this jake
tapper on cnn
just expressed his outrage his dismay
that the cdc
seems to have misrepresented data on the
coronavirus the hospitals are still
stretched in because of this so i'm not
trying to take away from that but if 40
in some hospitals 40 of the people who
have covid
don't necessarily have problematic covet
they're there because they got in a car
accident they they're there because
right um you know they they bump their
head
and they're being included as in the
hospital with covid that number seems
kind of misleading we're two years into
this and
we need the clearest picture possible if
somebody's in the hospital with a broken
leg and they also have asymptomatic
ovarian that should not be counted as
hospitalized with covet clearly
i can't believe you how dare you cdc how
dare you government officials
just just present this data in a
misleading way
where were the journalists where were
all the journalists to ask you these
questions two years ago when when when
we all just believe oh wait wait that's
right i'm a journalist oops
right i was supposed to be the one
asking those questions i'm glad that
jake tapper is either outraged or
pretending to be outraged now because
the
establishment and the ruling class was
lying to us for two years some of us by
the way i hate to say i told you so some
of us were calling this
two years ago
but i'm glad jake tapper has caught up
now
he should have been doing that the whole
time that's what an actual journalist
would have done
that's what
someone who's really
speaking truth to power and asking the
hard questions that's what they would
have done but that's that's not what
happened with our corporate media
because our corporate press are not
actually investigative reporters and
journalists and fighting back against
the entrenched power they're part of the
entrenched power
they're the same thing
the the progressives in our government
the hardcore progressives are not there
fighting against and sticking it to the
big corporations they're they're working
with the big corporations they're all on
the same side
and they're not getting asked the
questions of the media and they're not
having their
premises questioned by the intellectuals
in the academy that the the people who
are
doing research on their own the
scientists and the other sorts of
scholars who are also speaking truth to
power no they're all they're all just
working together
they're all just part of the same thing
and
whenever they appear to be in opposition
that's almost always just political
theater
the question is now why is jake tapper
suddenly changing his tune
well it's not just jake tapper it's
it's the whole
ruling class
do you think it's a coincidence that cnn
is now taking a more skeptical
more
i don't know calm
more reasonable approach to covid
at the very same time that joe biden is
trying to pivot on covid and joe biden
is saying look there's no federal
solution here look we're all just going
to have to get back to normal at the
very same time that the democrat
governor of new york is saying actually
the hospitalization numbers are being
exaggerated at the very same time as the
cdc director is saying actually the
hospitalization numbers or the death
numbers rather have been somewhat
exaggerated because of the issue of
comorbidities do you think it's just a
coincidence
that all of these various facets of
society many of which are supposed to be
pitted in opposition to one another or
just all of a sudden changing their tune
at the same time because why
because that is now in the interest of
the ruling class which has many
different facets to it
that's why because there are diminishing
political returns for the lockdowns and
forcing everyone to get the constant
jabs and and harping on kovid forever
and ever and ever
they've already seized the power that
they wanted to seize they've already
upended our society they've already
taken away of a lot of our liberties and
so they're all going to pivot and move
on to the next thing
and they're going to do it in concert
with one another
and the most offensive part of all is
they're going to pretend that they're
actually fighting one another the whole
time
they are going to relieve themselves on
your leg and tell you that it is raining
hey you
[Music]
it's nice to be with you nice to see you
i'm glad we could spend this time
together if you want to spend more time
together
ring my bell
that's right
ring my bell ll ring my bell you will
get the notifications you can also head
on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-n-w-l-e-s space
s-h-o-w see you next time
[Music]
[Music]